in the book uh as you would expect you
talk about
some of your favorite exercises and you
do a lot yeah what surprised me is you
said your favorite is pool dancing which
i know yes a pool dancing class which is
yeah really popular you know what's
funny and i i actually i i used to do it
like when i was like 25 i got into it
and then i just recently went back to
doing some pole dancing again and the
thing about it
is
it's not when you do it with women any
woman who is you know does it
you recognize that oh wait this is
actually about us
women in a circle of women like finding
something inside of ourselves that we
haven't really opened up that's not
about
being objectified it's actually about
our sensuality and it's an amazing
experience and it makes you incredibly
strong but it's really like this amazing
community of women sort of
like opening up and it's all about
opening up it's all about blossoming but
it's really you know not about putting
on a show right it's more about what it
feels like and it's one of my favorite
workouts is there music playing while
you do it oh it's a whole thing so but
it's not like pour some sugar on me oh
yeah by the way
one of my favorites yeah that's amazing
when i'm on the pole that's what i call
for yeah yeah
the uh the so
uh sly
singing uh
syrah
interestingly enough that's an
interesting choice interesting paul
dancing choice we had we had a poll i
think one of the women that helped start
this movement of pole dancing on the
show
back when i was in new york a couple
years ago and i was like yeah i'll do it
too
and i started doing it and you have to
be so strong in your upper body yeah and
your stomach
it's the best full body work it's like a
it's anything to climb you're basically
climbing it's like climbing a rope you
know and then you start being able to do
it without your feet and you just get
super strong it's amazing but then i had
i like wet my hair and was whipping it
back
i sat on a chair with leggings and
that's when it got
then they said this has nothing to do
with exercise
why are you doing this it's really fun i
made a lot of money